Pat forty who I almost said overrated
but I can't do that to Patty's he's too
nice properly rated whatever that is Pat
forty is properly rated joints on loan
do you get into these conversations
about best of all time and best team and
dynasty and LeBron and Michael
personally I think the the proper tag
for me is criminally underrated not you
know I'll stick with I'll stick with
properly rated that's fine um oh yeah
all the time
all the time and there is absolutely a
generational divide and there is kind of
a weird grudging thing with LeBron that
I don't get you know whether it's just
that LeBron's heyday is coincided with
the what I guess you could call hater
culture you know we're we're everybody
can be knocked down but I to me that if
this isn't just my opinion now it's sort
of the correct thing of course but it's
just my opinion that that you know
Jordans just the greatest winner ever
and if you and if there's going to be a
separator it's going to be that and
until they've LeBron gets to six world
titles then then we can have that
discussion but I think Jordan was a
superior winner oh yeah and and he has
he has a different gene but that genes
gonna come out in this documentary and
people are going to be a little bit
uncomfortable with what they see with
Michael Jordan's personality back then
we knew it we saw it we accepted it
that's just who he was but if Mike did
what he did you know back then did it
now social media would leave him alive
no doubt no doubt
punching teammates and there's some of
the other stuff yeah yeah sure that he
was he was excessive and it was it was
much more tolerant back then than it
would be today for sure oh man alright
so I wanted to have you on for a couple
of reasons here you saw where Jalen
Greene who was the top high school kid
out of Fresno he decided to go to the G
League and they sort of set up this
separate G League account or whatever it
is it's like come on in and you're gonna
get a half a million dollars and we'll
get you a shoe deal and you sort of hang
out here for a little while and develop
and then you'll go into the draft
next year what exactly is this program
it's like the commissioners exempt list
when he was you know the NFL
Commissioner where I didn't even know he
had an exempt list I didn't know the G
League had this yeah this is a very
interesting development and it seems to
me underscores what appears to be a bit
of disdain from the NBA side and now the
silver side sports college basketball
it's like whether it's the system is is
too corrupt or it's just not producing
Flip players that are ready enough or
whatever I think he's gone from yes I'll
work with the college game and you know
we'll eventually get rid of the H
minimum and you know take away some of
the ambiguity of these guys that are
going to school for one year and just
let them go straight in now it's like
yeah we're just gonna go rate the high
school guys and we don't care whether
they come to you or or not and so to me
it's a very interesting development if
they've got that kind of money to throw
around
kids are going to be very interested in
taking it now it may not be for many of
them but still if you're siphoning off
those kind of kids it definitely would
have an impact on the college game and I
mean I wrote about this that most
college kids that guys that are playing
college basketball don't want to be
there especially the good ones you know
they absolutely grew up dreaming of
playing for North Carolina or Duke or
Kentucky or Kansas or UCLA or anyone
else they don't want to be there
well Zion is the last he's the last
dinosaur he's the anomaly here but I I'm
wondering and I'm talking about this
superstar but why wouldn't adidas or
Nike just say we're setting up our own
little workshop here we're gonna pay you
we're gonna pay you whatever we have an
Academy you come in and we'll give you
life skills will teach how to balance a
checkbook we'll teach about real estate
we'll have simulated games we'll have
you know Nike former NBA players on
staff who'll come in and work you out
and give you tips advisers to help you
go into the NBA why not just do that get
them under contract with a shoe deal and
send them into the draft to me it feels
like you would be investing in your
future if your Nike or adidas and then
these kids who don't want to go to
school actually learn what they need to
learn going into the NBA I mean makes a
lot of sense on the face of it you know
is that soon as you you prepare them in
the ways that they need to be prepared
as far as taking care of money and some
life skills and that sort of thing and
then yeah you get them under your wing
and that's I mean so many of these
players already are yes you know
considered in silos and Nike there's
that's a Nike kit that's an Under Armour
kit that he just kid so yeah why not
extend it and further cut out the the
college middleman so to speak you know I
wouldn't be surprised if those ideas are
percolating in places even beyond the
high reaches of the Dan Patrick show Pat
forty Sports Illustrated college sports
senior writer head Chris Fowler on the
show earlier in the week and we talked
about if there's gonna be lost revenue
with college football and the
trickle-down with other sports here I'm
wondering can you rip up that contract
that ESPN has with college football with
the Final Four and then we extrapolate
this and make it the sweet 16 like you
know all options on the table but can we
get do you think that we can get to that
point this year well college football
has been the hardest entity to get to
change anything
over the centuries what they call
contracts are made to be broken and
there has never been a time that really
looks as economically challenging as
this one so yeah I would not absolutely
shocked me you know they could even bill
it as a one-time thing to see how it
goes and then you know if it's not good
we can go back the other way but you
know the football cash cow is so vital
and if it's going to be compromised and
I think we've already started to see
some of the repercussions of its sports
being cut and pay cuts all over the
place and staff being reduced and
furloughs all those sort of things if
there is an easy fix a relatively easy
fix
16 play off 18 play off 12 team play off
16 team play off one-time only let's see
how it goes yeah I think it could happen
yeah it's given the the hunger in sports
media and in college athletics for
revenue and what
not coming in now and it may not come in
for several more months would not shock
me and I just thought of this
JT Daniels the big-time recruit at USC
just entered the transfer portal he was
you know heralded as a you know next
great quarterback at USC and I and I
started to think about this did Ed or
Geron recruit JT Daniels at USC and
therefore Joe burrow is gone hey come on
down here to Baton Rouge I'm just
thinking out loud here yeah I'm not sure
it may be it may be some early stages
recruiting you know JT JT left high
school actually a year earlier that's
just you know so he was he was a young
freshman and he was the starter but sure
I mean a guy like that look people
really liked his talent you know he was
thrown into the fire as a young freshman
by the end of the year he was playing
pretty well a game against Notre Dame I
remember that he was good and then you
know he gets hurt the next year and then
Keaton slovis comes in and is really
good and and definitely the favorite of
the offensive coordinator Graham Harrell
so yeah this is a high quality
quarterback suddenly on the market now
he's gonna have to sit almost assuredly
but yeah I would think he would be super
attractive to LSU and anybody else that
needs a quarterback yeah I know they got
Myles Brennan but if eddo recruited him
when he was at USC and no and just a
thought just a thought pattern that's
all I do like just think it's great to
talk to you as always hope the family
safe and we'll keep reading thanks Pat
40 Sports Illustrated college sports
senior writer